so president trump is now former
president trump and joe biden is now the
current president of the united states
and as many have pointed out that means
that donald trump is now
a private citizen so to whatever extent
that president trump had immunity as
president that no longer applies and as
a private citizen
trump can now be sued and investigated
for all of the things that he may or may
not have done
and there were a lot of open questions
as president can a sitting president be
indicted can they be investigated can
they
apply executive privilege whenever they
want and you'd think as a private
citizen a lot of those questions would
be answered but the truth is there are a
lot of open questions still
if and when former president trump is
investigated he will claim
some sort of residual immunity and these
are still questions that will have to be
litigated
and answered by the courts for any of
these investigations to go forward
because this wasn't a normal presidency
and he wasn't a normal president so stay
tuned for
more presidential legal news and as
always i'll see you
in court